Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
In questo titolo "Open to -"
abbiamo scelto di [inserire] "Action".
Action vuol dire --
sono dovuto andare a guardare
sul dizionario, per essere sicuro:
"Essere aperti a nuove idee,
a nuove prospettive,
a rivalutare la quotidianità,
a guardare le cose in modo diverso."
È anche un'azione,
è una chiamata a fare qualcosa,
a non star fermo.
Quindi vorrei parlare,
in questi 17 minuti che restano,
di qualcosa di diverso,
di qualcosa che sta fuori da questo mondo,
apparentemente lontano
ma molto vicino a noi.
Stazione Spaziale Internazionale,
una casa laboratorio
che gira attorno alla Terra
a 28.000 chilometri all'ora.
Andiamo lassù perché troviamo lassù
delle cose che non ci sono
qui sulla Terra,
e paradossalmente possiamo
cercare e scoprire
cose che poi ci aiutano
nella vita di tutti i giorni.
È un posto isolato, confinato:
non è facile arrivarci,
bisogna prendere un razzo.
Non è che ci sono, poi,
così dietro l'angolo.
È un po' come avere
una mini bomba atomica di sotto
che quando si accende
ti spara verso l'alto.
Non ci vuole moltissimo,
ad arrivare ai 400 chilometri di quota
della Stazione Spaziale Internazionale.
Diciamo otto minuti e mezzo:
è come Milano Roma in otto minuti e mezzo,
più o meno.
Dopodiché ti avvicini
alla Stazione Spaziale
e finalmente, se va tutto bene,
e di solito va [bene],
entri a far parte di questo nucleo
di extraterrestri -
perché io ci credo
agli extraterrestri: eravamo noi!
Questi extraterrestri che sono lì
a, sostanzialmente, vivere e lavorare
in questa casa laboratorio.
E qui cominciano subito i problemi,
perché sostanzialmente
tu ti sei addestrato
per anni e anni, anche dieci anni,
e arrivi sù e non capisci più niente.
Scherzando, si dice
che il tuo quoziente d'intelligenza,
quando arrivi in orbita,
si divide per tre.
Perché sostanzialmente il tuo cervello
è impegnato a capire
che cosa sta succedendo.
Tu ti sei addestrato,
conosci esattamente
tutto quello che c'è attorno,
ma non hai previsto il fatto
che non senti più la forza di gravità.
E quindi quando arrivi
e cerchi di mantenere i piedi
verso il "pavimento",
quello dove c'è scritto deck,
scopri che non c'è.
C'è scritto "deck", ma non è il pavimento.
Qual è che è giusto? È lui? Sono io?
Sono quegli altri laggiù in fondo? Boh!
E questo è un po' quello che succede
quando siamo qua sulla Terra,
lo abbiamo sentito anche prima:
la vita è un continuo cambiamento.
Quando noi impariamo a fare qualcosa,
e lo facciamo bene
e non facciamo nient'altro,
ci siamo messi sulla via
dell'autodistruzione.
Perché se la vita cambia,
le cose cambiano,
quello che ti sta attorno cambia
e tu non cambi,
perderai il lavoro e non andrai avanti.
Quindi qui hai una scelta:
o diventi un extraterrestre
e cerchi di capire che cos'è,
o stai lì a farti mancare
quelle cose che non troverai mai.
È inutile che ti metti a piangere
che non c'è la forza di gravità:
"Rivoglio la forza di gravità!
Sto mangiando le cose e mi vola via tutto!
Non trovo più niente,
li cerco per terra e non sono lì!"
Ecco, è inutile che fai queste cose.
Questo è quello che facciamo
normalmente nella vita:
non cerchiamo di cambiare,
questa inerzia che abbiamo
a questo cambiamento
che poi di fatto è cercare di capire
come fare a ottenere dei risultati
in questa nuova situazione.
Non è semplice:
è difficile, quando non sai cosa fare,
guardare avanti, esplorare e fare;
ma è quello che dobbiamo fare.
Quindi, quando capisci
che non è necessario
tenere i piedi verso la Terra,
tenersi con le mani lì
per cercare di stare veramente...
lascia andare tutto, non trovi più niente
e fai come Scott
che era già lì da tre mesi
che è già diventato extraterrestre,
lì, bello pacifico, tranquillo,
lassù sembrava un vampiro,
quando l'ho guardato.
"Io voglio dormire qua,
perché lì si dorme meglio".
Quando di fatto ho capito
che era esattamente la stessa cosa.
E quindi questo cambiamento,
questa inerzia -
è una cosa che dovremmo fare:
cambiare la prospettiva.
Invece di continuare a guardare
quello che ci manca,
Guardare a quello che c'è,
ma che non scopriremo mai
se non ci lavoreremo.
La Stazione Spaziale
è un posto dove si lavora,
a dire la verità.
Ti fanno lavorare
dalle sette e mezza di mattina
alle sette e mezza di sera,
all'orario di servizio.
Qui fai tutta una serie
di attività, di esperimenti;
e non sei tu che decidi, è Houston.
Ma la sera - la sera..
chissà la sera, quale sarà:
quando non sei di servizio,
mettiamola così -
abbiamo la capacità
di andare alla finestra
e guardare di sotto
e di sotto si vedono
delle cose incredibili
che cerchiamo di fotografare,
una delle cose belle che possiamo fare.
E vedi una cosa come questa.
Questa è l'Italia.
Questa è l'Italia vista da sud
che ho fotografato in 6K,
la trovate in questo video
dell'Agenzia Spaziale Europea
su YouTube, volendo.
E si vede l'Italia
come [normalmente] non la vedi.
Questo è un passaggio in tempo reale,
si vede fino in fondo,
lo dovrò fermare tra poco.
Ma vedete un po' le Alpi, qua sopra,
che ci riparano dal vento del nord.
Abbiamo il mare Mediterraneo,
sotto e attorno,
che ci tempera l'atmosfera.
Dovremmo essere molto più freddi:
siamo a 45 gradi, piuttosto alti.
Insomma un Paese veramente,
incredibilmente baciato dalla natura.
E poi, quando lo guardi
con più attenzione,
rivedi di nuovo l'Italia,
ma capita che la vedi così.
E cominci a pensare: ma dove siamo noi?
In Val Padana.
E in Val Padana, spesso e volentieri
la situazione non è delle più rosee.
Difatti, ogni tanto si ferma
la circolazione a Milano.
Ma insomma, è un po'
più piccola, Milano.
E questo è quello che ti permette di fare,
di guardare la Terra dalla stazione,
di vedere le cose tirandoti indietro
e abbracciare una visione più completa.
E dico sempre:
guardare la terra da quaggiù
è come pretendere di vedere un ritratto
mettendo il naso appoggiato alla tela.
Vedo qualche dettaglio,
ma non vedo questo ritratto.
[È questa la prospettiva]
che ti spiega le cose: guardate lassù.
Dove siamo qui?
Bellagio, l'avete riconosciuto,
il lago di Como,
noi siamo più o meno
sotto questa nuvoletta qua.
Va bene.
Ma noi non ci rendiamo conto
di come la natura non sia esattamente
come la pensiamo noi.
Questa è una serie di fiumi in Argentina,
a sud di Buenos Aires,
Ed è interessante come,
tutte le volte che ci passi sopra,
cambiano, sono diversi.
Perché i fiumi cercano di andare
dove c'è meno resistenza.
Questo è l'Orinoco in Sudamerica:
guardate questa foto,
dove si vede sostanzialmente
quante volte questo fiume
ha cambiato il suo corso,
nel corso degli anni.
Noi pensiamo che i fiumi siano
delle strutture che sono ferme:
ma non è vero per niente,
questi si muovono.
Se li dovessimo guardare -
noi coi nostri occhi da terrestri,
che dieci anni ci sembrano tanti,
mille chilometri sembrano tanti,
se li guardassimo con gli occhi
di un extraterrestre,
vedremo che i fiumi sono delle cose vive,
che si muovono in continuazione.
Questo è il Gran Canyon,
che ha scavato addirittura
delle valli profonde due chilometri.
Ha portato via tutto quello
che c'era lì dentro,
e l'ha portato da un'altra parte.
Questo è il Mississipi,
che nel 2011 ha deciso di straripare
e ha mandato sott'acqua
tutta una serie di città.
Noi diciamo: "Ma il Mississipi
straripa, ma come?"
Ma questo è quello che fanno i fiumi:
quando si bloccano da qualche parte,
risalgono dall'altra.
E dove costruiamo noi le città?
Vicino ai fiumi,
perché è molto più semplice:
ci serve, l'acqua.
Non ci rendiamo conto
che poi i fiumi vanno fuori.
Sempre una visione generale:
i Caraibi, poi, quando li vai
a guardare da vicino,
vedi le sabbie tirate,
vedi queste isolette,
vedi questi spettacoli da lassù.
Sembrano casuali, ma non sono
poi così tanto casuali.
Qui siamo siamo in Australia.
E poi guardi qualcosa:
che abbiamo cominciato a costruire
dragando tutte le sabbie
e le barriere coralline
perché non ci basta,
abbiamo le città piene.
Quindi costruiamo qualcosa fuori.
E non ci rendiamo conto
che stiamo cambiando totalmente
la natura qua attorno.
Questa è Venezia.
Venezia ogni tanto va sott'acqua.
Non so se è stata una bella idea,
costruire una città lì.
Ma insomma dovremmo anche capire che -
Venezia è bellissima,
c'ero meno di una settimana fa.
Però è un po' problematica, la situazione.
Questo è il Vesuvio visto dallo spazio,
ed è interessante come vedi
tutta una serie di abitazioni, lì attorno;
se fai una foto di notte,
vedi dov'è esattamente il Vesuvio.
Attorno ci sono un milione di persone.
Se quello scoppia,
come ha fatto un po' di tempo fa,
qui c'è qualche problema,
dovremo stare attenti.
L'Italia, super luminosissima:
sembra che abbiamo elettricità gratis,
che ce la danno gratis.
Guardate un po' il resto
dell'Europa, quasi scura.
Poi arriva Milano, arriviamo noi
che bruciamo energia
senza nessun problema.
Eccola qua Milano,
vista dall'alto tra l'altro.
L'Italia è molto, molto bella.
Come ripeto,
è un Paese incredibile visto da lassù.
Dovremo stare attenti, però,
alle risorse che abbiamo.
Chiudo questo talk con un video,
un video che trovate su Youtube.
Anche questo, se fate una ricerca
per "The Sound of Silence NASA",
trovate questo video
pubblicato dalla NASA.
L'abbiamo fatto con la NASA
quando eravamo in orbita.
Io facevo un bel po'
di fotografie di passaggi,
ne ho fatte qualcosa come 500.000.
Il russo faceva i dettagli, e quindi
abbiamo messo assieme questa cosa.
Quindi volevo vederla assieme a voi
perché vi fa vedere un po'
come si vede la Terra da lassù.
e com'è diversa,
e come dovremmo guardarla
in un modo diverso
per poter andare a questo action,
per fare qualcosa, per fare delle azioni,
per stare attenti a cosa facciamo.
Questa è l'alba vista dallo spazio,
ci vogliono circa sette secondi
per passare dalla dalla notte al giorno.
Poi quando, sette secondi dopo,
si "accende" il mondo,
e vedi tutto bianco e blu,
nuvole e oceani.
Poi ogni tanto qualche terra,
qualcosa la vedi,
ma è veramente difficile capire
anche dove sei o che cos'è.
C'è una visione più completa,
qualcosa di strano.
Questa è l'ombra della Luna,
in un eclissi di Sole
che abbiamo fotografato dallo spazio.
Questa è l'Italia.
E guardate l'Africa, dietro l'angolo:
siamo proprio attaccati all'Africa.
Questa è Londra, vista dallo spazio.
Questa è Roma:
la Stazione Termini, il Colosseo.
Di notte si accendono, le città.
Questa è la Mecca, in Arabia Saudita.
I ghiacciai della Patagonia.
Una Aurora Australis.
La Luna con tutti i pianeti allineati,
in questa alba lunare.
Di notte si accendono, le città.
Questo è il nord degli Stati Uniti.
Siamo dappertutto,
come su un albero di Natale.
Un temporale lassù.
Questo è Washington, negli Stati Uniti.
Questa è Mosca:
18 milioni di persone in questo anello.
Un atollo nel Pacifico.
La Grecia, scura;
e l'Africa, bruciata dal sole.
Delle isole, in Egitto.
Un lago in Australia.
Una vista nel deserto del Sahara.
Un impatto di un meteorite, nel Sahara.
Un vulcano nella Kamčatka.
Un uragano arrivato contro Houston,
quando eravamo in orbita.
L'occhio di un tifone
arrivato contro il Giappone.
I Caraibi, una macchia
smeraldo sopra la terra.
Qui volevo prendere l'Italia,
questa è la Spagna, l'Africa,
il Mar Mediterraneo.
Arriva l'Italia, arriva l'Italia,
arriva... un nuvolone incredibile.
Però ha preso la Puglia.
In Africa: nei deserti non ci sono nuvole.
Il Nilo, il Sinai, Israele,
Arabia Saudita, Mar Rosso.
L'aurora borealis.
Un fiume del Madagascar,
rosso per le deforestazioni.
Una strada in un deserto dell'Iran.
I deserti della Namibia.
New York.
Parigi.
E ancora una visione d'insieme,
dove non si vedono le nostre mini-nazioni:
si vede qualcosa, ma non si vede molto.
Perché alla fine,
ci sono considerazioni da fare.
E lascio finire questo video,
e poi facciamo un paio
di considerazioni in chiusura.
(Applausi)
Vi dicevo che quando sei lontano
non vedi più i dettagli.
Ma vedi qualcosa di insieme,
che è estremamente importante.
Uno guarda e vede qualche terra, qualcosa:
ma di fatto quello che succede
è che noi siamo qua sotto,
nelle nostre case, nei nostri giardini
e nelle nostre città
e non ci rendiamo conto
che siamo qua sotto
e abbiamo sopra di noi un muro,
un confine, che è questo.
Quando il sole se ne va,
e resta acceso per qualche minuto,
è l'atmosfera.
Quello è il nostro muro, che ci divide
tra i nostri mini confini,
i nostri mini giardinetti
e il vuoto dell'universo.
Se non ci fosse questo muro,
non ci saremmo.
Quindi dobbiamo stare attenti
a quello che facciamo:
ai nostri giardinetti, va bene;
ma anche a quel muro,
perché senza quel muro non ci saremmo.
Grazie.
(Applausi)